one thing I think that we should all
appreciate about From Software's recent
titles is how they often align their
games with the player experience so if
you take their soul spawn games for
example you often play a character who
is struggling to survive in a really
dangerous world and yet they're also a
character who can only really die if
they give up the same is true of the
player who is playing a really difficult
game and where true failure only comes
from giving up and when you stop playing
the story of the character resonates
with the player of the game and that's a
pretty powerful thing they resume aligns
the player experience in exactly the
same way except this time it's with VR
so when miyazaki the game's director
said he first experienced vr he said he
felt an impressive sense of presence as
if the VR characters existed while
simultaneously he also felt absent and
disconnected from their world
darris na captures that feeling in the
story sense because in the game you play
as an invisible fairy someone who can
interact with the world and the children
around you and yet you're also strangely
disconnected and distant from their
lives so you get that sensation from the
story you get that sensation from VR as
well and having them both overlap is a
pretty cool experience now is it a
pretty cool experience that's worth
buying PlayStation VR a PlayStation
camera and two PlayStation Move
controllers for you enjoy the video if
you've already watched the previous
video you'll already know the entire
backstory of Dera sanae you'll know how
the fairies came to exist how they
operates and you'll have just learned
the identity of us
the player character if you haven't
watched don't worry this video will take
you through the game as if as if you
just spent four hundred bucks on psvr
for one game like I did
every new fairy gets a little gift find
the golden wand and touch it with your
hand golden ones act as a sort of
catalyst for a human's time allowing a
fairy to drain a human's remaining time
into a red ring of life of course it
doesn't actually look like we're
draining a human's life force here but
if you look carefully you'll notice that
there are human sized lumps in all of
these beds you should remember that this
red ring is a gift given to fairies try
putting it on your right hand
we're taken to a dark place where the
snows of time fall and a character who
signs off as Abigail guides us to our
blue ring of time find the other one and
you'll see how life and times are holdin
to the rings with both rings in our
possession we set about exploring the
castle grounds and we start to meet all
of the children there's this photograph
in the chapel that reveals five of the
children and the day they arrived and
welcoming them all in the middle is a
woman named margarita she is an
incredibly important character to this
story this photo also features Herman
Laurence Nils Murray
and lastly yuria that last name will be
really familiar to a lot of seoul's fans
the name Yulia is pretty much in every
recent fromsoftware game honestly it's
almost on par with patches and the
moonlight greatsword at this point of
all the children yulia is perhaps the
most important becoming a sort of
protagonist or even antagonist at times
and unlike the other children what makes
her special is that she has a very keen
sense for fairies
gave me I wonder if the ferry makes the
flower bloom as a sign and I go to tell
them now grass is withered light
securely is in your right hand and use
the red ring to bestow it with time
[Music]
kind fairy I'm so happy to meet you
thank you for giving me a sign my name
is Yulia will you be our friend for this
you said about convincing the other
children that you exist Yulia has
basically decided that the best way to
do this and to convince the other
children is to half poison lawrence by
spiking his stew with a bunch of herbs
each child has hidden there herbs and
you're supposed to look for these clues
in the children's echos and then use
those clues to find the herbs on their
physical bodies this is what makes up
the core of the gameplay in de Rosnay
and it's a good sort of puzzle don't get
me wrong but there's such a
point-and-click style adventure game I
would have loved to see a bit more
variety in the puzzles anyway this is
Marie she's a sort of motherly figure to
the other children and one of her
rituals is to go around the Academy
opening all the windows to let fresh air
in oh goodness Haman he's gone to sleep
up there again I know how much he likes
it but seeping up in trees is much too
dangerous I'll have to speak with him
later that is Herman he's a quiet kid
who enjoys sleeping up in high places
and he keeps all kinds of things under
his hat down below we find the echos of
the other two children Rosa and Nils
they're working together to hide their
hubs and they've got them locked in a
box in an attic Nils a kid who is always
found with his head in a book has the
key
my mistake the key to the box is gone I
can't believe it the ferry it's real and
Rosa the youngest this sweet crippled
girl with a walking stick watches over
the herbs I'm so glad to meet you
I'm Rosa please kind fairy please be
friends with us throughout the story you
repeatedly hear that Rosa's right leg
was actually crippled in what is a
pretty supernatural event and we'll
learn about that later anyway the last
of the herbs are tied around the dog's
neck and while you're tracking them down
you actually hear this really curious
line of dialogue you must really miss
you Lea hey boy fine
I'll let you hold on to my herbs
but just for a bit okay I miss her too
easy it's your first clue that Yulia
isn't physically here even though she
appears to be right in setting out to
prove that fairies exist
the children are simply humoring some of
you Lea's last wishes and beliefs yep
fairies exist you've outdone yourself
Julia and it's easy to think that Yulia
may also be a fairy just like us but she
can't be because she can interact with
cats in which all fairies fear instead I
think of Yulia as a sort of garrison a
the word duress name means to be
uprooted or a nomad and Yulia is a sort
of half fairy half physical being
she doesn't really belong in either
world and she's unable to leave her
fellow orphans behind and Yulia isn't
the only character stuck in the past the
headmaster too is absolutely consumed by
his regret
[Laughter]
another Christmas committed of ignorance
we are requests by a various physical
yet I am not permitted to shave down my
time to say one poor girl this is a man
consumed by guilt so much so that he's
willing to trade all of his remaining
time for one last good act the act has
to do with Rosa the young redhead go on
the Headmaster's floor is a letter that
she wrote to him on the night of the
storm when I hurt my leg I saw something
I shouldn't have every night in my dream
the thing touches my leg that's why it
never heals and never stops hurting
night after night after night
please headmaster what should I do
because of this letter and because a
fairy has arrived at the school the
headmaster decides to give his remaining
time to us so that we can help Rosa
kind fairy you have my fullest gratitude
now take the wand and take my time on
this earth indeed take my time unto
yourself and please if you would be so
kind spare the girl closer
so we go back in time to the 4th of
February when Rosa hurt her leg and I
love this scene the storm is so
atmospheric and fantastic and there are
a lot of cool moments where you can use
your head tracking to sort of look out
the window tonight the boy Nils has an
awful fever and all of the children are
fretting about how best to help him
sleep
Laurence and Marie Muse over a herbal
remedy Herrmann watches over him to keep
him calm and Rosa Rosa stares out of her
window thinking about a book she read
that said that the red ring of a fairy
can heal and as she looks down at the
wharf and as we Crane our neck to sort
of see what she's looking at she sees a
red glow the resume is at its best when
it let's use the head-tracking like this
and what you see down there does
actually look pretty sinister if we
don't put Rosa to sleep she'll go down
there and she'll see something terrible
something that will drain the life from
her leg and touch it every night in her
dreams preventing it from healing and
crippling the poor girl
so we get the incense that we used for
Nils and we soothe Rosa with it as well
and we stop her going outside and we
fulfill the Headmaster's wish when you
go back to the future Rosa's leg is
actually healed but you're left with a
curious question what was that red light
down there and why did it look so human
oh and by her side in this scene is a
doll named Fiona check this out so this
is one of the major blood-borne
references in garrison a and it may even
hint at blood-borne two but we'll talk
about this and many other blood-borne
references in another video when we
travel forward in time again Rosa's leg
is healed and back in this time the
children are now convinced that you
because you discovered all of their
hidden herbs and you put them in
Lawrence's pot so next they set about
finding a spot for your chair if you've
been visited by a fairy it's customary
to provide it with a chair if the fairy
fancies the spot that it's given it will
stay for a very long time why don't we
ask everyone where they think the chair
should go everyone can think of a spot
write it down and we'll gather all the
ideas together there are seven options
and the place you choose can unlock a
few story points that are unique to your
playthrough and I got to admit it wasn't
fun going through every one of these
because I had to like save the game and
then keep reloading my saves and seeing
what changed and took a lot of time but
the best one you can choose is the
chapel decking it gives you a good bit
of dialogue later on in the game once
you've chosen it once you've chosen a
spot the children decide to play a song
to welcome you to the school they've
chosen one of you Leah's favorites it's
a song called Scarborough Fair oh and
this is the scene where patches actually
appears in the game it's not a very
interesting character this time around
unfortunately for the children in this
scene the music box is broken and
according to this book the fairies music
box is actually the voice of the fairy
and to fix this music box you have to
find the cogs that spin it but one of
them was actually swallowed by one of
the children's pet mouse called new who
choked to death actually and to get it
back you have to transfer life from this
snake to new which gets you the missing
gear and sets events into motion that
will eventually lead to the children
leaving the school into the dangerous
outdoors I wish there was more life
transferring in the game but this
instance of life transference in
particular sets off events and story
that will have a huge impact in the
story later on
but first the children practice their
new song after realizing that you are
there and that it was you who fixed the
music box
[Music]
have a look at Yulia in the back
she actually waves at you if you look
closely
[Music]
at this point in time Yulia is dead and
it's quite possible that it was you who
took her life
amazing performance that you think with
the fairy singing through the music box
yes
it was Lawrence I'm so glad we went with
that song only it made me wonder how
beautiful it would have been if you Leo
were here to sing with us we skip
forward to the 3rd of November in a
classroom written on the chalkboard are
the words were going outside be back
soon along with the key to the infirmary
and inside the infirmary sitting quietly
on the bed is the drained corpse of
Yulia which the children didn't bury for
some reason that's strange but they too
are very guilty of obsessing over the
past and this inclination this holding
onto the past puts them into mortal
danger as well because yulia's ghost
implores us kind fairy you're here I
must ask you something
you're the only one I can turn to please
read the letter it reads dear fairy I
beg of you go to the forest and save
them all they must not venture beyond
the grounds or they will lose everything
around the corner you find an open
supply closet which leads to a secret
tunnel that leads out of the school the
children have actually ventured outside
the Academy in a quest to bring you
Lea's corpse back to life and the
children go on this adventure because
they realized that you the kind fairy
revived new Nils as pet rat one more
time yes
I'm sure it wasn't just any Mouse it was
the fairy brought it back to life to
repair the music box through their
research and your intervention they
realized that fairies can actually
transfer life between beings as long as
the two things are similar in size we
can't just give up and so to bring Yulia
back to life they'll have to find a
larger life form something that exists
outside of the Academy
take the time one has to live just like
in the story so if we ask nicely the
fairy will bring Yulia back to life
well it's certainly worth a try but the
fairy would need the life of something
very large and strong
but as soon as they're outside the group
get separated and they're not the only
beings out there take special note of
these spinning signposts of cats the
things that fairies fear oh now I can
see it yes something's moving okay I'll
go and see what it is you just wait
heroes up Bailey are you sure in a scene
to come
we realized that Nils never does come
back so Rosa the youngest is forced to
set out alone in search of the others
[Music]
[Music]
voice actors by the way is incredible
she has some really moving scenes
[Music]
what are you doing out here without a
cat
fairies lurk in these parts children we
can talk later hurry come inside unless
you want to be fairy feed a great moment
in this game is seeing the other fairy
move as up until now you've sort of
taken for granted how frozen everything
is and how safe you are in this
environment and now that you see this
thing trying to get through a locked
door which is something that you've been
trying to do the whole game by the way
you sort of really struck by it a little
bit more powerfully and honestly I would
have loved to see them do like a stealth
sequence or something here I think they
really needed to open up the gameplay to
take this game to the next level but
anyway we go further up and we realized
that Lawrence Herman and the old man who
lives in this forest left to go and get
firewood and while they were out there
they were ambushed by the evil fairy
waited up and vanished was it
the evil fairy
run away I have to get away
it kills the old man and takes his
lifeforce and we see the ghost of
Lawrence struggling to leave and if
you've been playing your remember we
actually saw the real physical form of
Lawrence really far out of the forest
because as soon as Lawrence saw this he
actually grabbed the old man's cat and
then left all of his fellow children to
their fate alone in the forest herman on
the other hand tries to distract the
evil fairy by lighting a torch boy
evil fairy I'm right here take it
whatever time I had while he does so
Rosa finally discovers the cabin and she
heads inside to reunite with Louie
mary-rose is gone I went looking for him
huh man's voice and then I found this
house good night okay it's okay Rosa
calm down you'll be just fine
she was the only child left outside at
this point back at the academy you might
have actually read a book about this
forest this is a forest called Rob's
forest and it reads in the end the
residents of Rob's forest disappeared
disappearances continued till this day
and Rosa left the door open
stop right there my dear that time
you've got your eye on it belongs to
those girls it's not for you to muck
about with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where are you how good is that voice
acting anyway on a desk we find a
photograph of five adults they're
gathered around a golden wand and we
realized that these are the scholars of
Rouen
they're the five adults who planned to
turn into fairies and fixed the past a
plan that went terribly wrong
on the right is margarita and on the
left of her with the glasses must be our
headmaster one of these other men must
be the old man another of them must be
the evil fairy and there is a book in
the back room that's written by a man
called Nicholas it reads the moment we
become fairies with our golden once the
world becomes a place of endless
possibility mistakes of the past will be
undone and the future will only hold
what is right what on earth are we
waiting for
Marone Ian's colleagues I say again what
on earth are we waiting for
remember this is the group of five Rhoni
and scholars that set this story into
motion after things went wrong in road
and in Rob's forest Margaretta and the
headmaster started the school and
adopted the five orphans they plan to
experiment with the orphans using them
to attract fairies but they weren't the
main experiment Margarita's daughter a
baby named alexis was out the back door
to the Academy is a grave that reads
Alexis taken like a leaf in the wind and
by her grave a summary of research
findings on faeries humans who have
become faeries claimed life to travel to
the past likely their human instincts at
work a person who is not obsessed by the
past might prove an exception perhaps a
newborn baby would make an ideal
candidate and so margarita and the
headmaster must have attempted to turn
Alexis into a fair
believing that a very without attachment
to the past couldn't possibly turn evil
however sometime after this it appears
that Margaretta committed suicide
throwing herself into the river of
prayer a note in the Headmaster's office
reads many moons have passed since he
gave herself to the river Yulia is dead
now the children are gone too if this is
the debt for my sins and heaven forbid I
ever sin again is it too early to join
you margretta at this point in time it's
suggested that the headmaster too threw
himself in the river as you find his
chair here it must have been out of an
intense guilt about all this horror that
is brought about but one child still
remains
[Music]
at all fluoroscopy how great please
let's be rid of that key I must have
dozed off
oh you fool arts tonight the fairy could
very well be here
dear fairy kindest fairy I humbly
implore you
[Music]
take whatever time I have remaining
please use it to spare the others from
their fate for you are kind fairy I beg
of you please help them
[Applause]
[Music]
so you have to stop the children ever
going to the forest and to do this first
you decide to flush the key to the gate
away you give Nils the book on the
vanishings of Rob's forest so he can
learn about it and you set the corpse of
new adrift down the river so that the
children will never learn that faeries
could bring Yulia back to life but it's
not enough Nils studies up on even more
books learning that fairies are
responsible for disappearances by the
oceans in the cities and in the forest
and even without new coming back to life
without the key and with all the
warnings about the forest some children
still venture out and die to the evil
fairy that's how strong their will is to
save their friend Yulia that no amount
of dissuasion stops them from venturing
out on her behalf and eventually you
decide the only way to stop them from
reviving Yulia is to revive Yulia
yourself so you take the life of
Lawrence to go back to the 22nd of
October where you take the life of the
headmaster to go back even further to
the 4th of February where I believe
Yulia is actually still alive praying in
the chapel it's the same stormy night
that Rosa steals the key to the back
door during the storm for she plans to
investigate that red glow that came up
from the river so we get the key and we
go outside
it's open
I suppose it wasn't no
the corpse wears a red ring of life
which could explain why it's still
moving and it also wears a collar that
was commonly passed from mother to
daughter
the name margarita is etched inside so
this is margarita the woman who founded
this school with the headmaster the
mother to Alexis and the woman who
killed herself when she realized that
Alexis was gone but why margarita threw
herself in the river is likely to be one
of the bigger questions in darris na the
simple answer is that it was done out of
grief the grave of her daughter Alexis
after all is just around the corner a
more likely answer though might be that
margarita actually tried to become a
fairy to go back in time and to stop her
daughter from dying or becoming a fairy
to turn into a fairy it seems like you
need to die and be given a red ring of
life I think and by taking the red ring
of life with her it's possible she also
wanted to thwart the plan to turn Alexis
into a fairy if you guys have any ideas
on this and you've played the game I
would love to hear them as well one more
answer is that Margaret had drowned
herself to pass on the life ring maybe
it was some omniscient act of
self-sacrifice perhaps she knew that
this red ring imbued with her lifeforce
could play a part in your story to come
and it certainly does with this red ring
full of human life we revived you Leah
what's happening I'm alive again kind
fairy do I have you to thank for this a
few weeks later all appears to be going
really well
the echoes of the children engaged in
their favorite activities Marie is
freshening up the place and opening
windows Nils has a stack full of books
to read
Herman's asleep in a tree and just that
morning Yulia was reading a book on
fairies this book talks about how the
only special type of time is that which
governs your own lifespan and that those
who try to steal time for themselves
turn into something else entirely you go
downstairs and the music that has played
your entire playthrough stops
all the children are dead killed by an
evil fairy I lost my life but I refuse
to say goodbye and became a wicked fairy
I deserved it
even the headmaster is gone the children
were on their way to the recital to play
their song in appreciation of you and
all that you did for them and then Yulia
stole their remaining time so you take
back her hand-woven ring which was a
symbol of the bond that all the children
share and yet again her regret over the
past forces you to go back in time kind
fairy are you there please bring them
back they're gone all of them I stole
their time on this earth I'll turn evil
again soon before I do take my remaining
time use it to rescue them
[Music]
thank you kind ferry there in your hands
[Music]
doesn't leave one way to stop all of
this for sure really you have to
discover what killed Yulia in the first
place and it turns out Yulia died at
midnight on June 1st the same night you
went through the tutorial and the same
night you became a fairy
you are Alexis the baby that was turned
into a fairy
you are margaritas daughter for upstairs
in the Attic there's a photograph of a
baby holding a golden wand it says that
the baby has a birthmark on their left
hand and so do you the night you become
a fairy julius told the Headmaster's
golden wand she must have been close to
you when you were a baby and so she
wanted to take the golden wand and make
a wish a wish to see Margaret as
daughter Alexis again and so this is the
night that you turned into a fairy you
were drawn to the golden wand in her
hands and unknowingly at the time you
drained her life force so that you could
obtain a ring of life strangely the
first time you do this you can't see the
children in their beds and while I don't
know why you can't see them they're
definitely there you can see the lumps
in their beds anyway it was you who set
all of these events into motion and in
the end the story comes full circle
but you actually have three decisions to
make here first you can take yulia's
life just as you did the first time and
go through all of this again
second you can opt to never touch the
golden wand at all and third when you
take the life from Yuliya you don't have
to put the ring of life on your right
hand
instead you can give yulia's life back
to her every new fairy after all gets a
little gift and instead of being gifted
back Margarita's remaining time you give
her back her own something that she will
always treasure from this point on
in a nearby bedside table you find the
book unseen fairies it speaks of a fairy
who could not find their ring and so
they could not traverse the stillness of
time so they went off perfectly
unnoticed fading off unceremoniously
into the darkness where the snows of
time fall yes it was all thanks to the
fairy I was ailing in bed and tried to
give the last of my time to the fairy
but at some point I nodded off then in a
dream the fairy drained every drop of
time that I had but as quickly as it
happened the fairy gave it back it was
my time for my life and it felt so very
warm
I'll never waste a moment of it again
with her own life gifted back to her
instead of margaret's his life gifted to
her Yulia never commits evil against the
other children they go on to live
happily together as if you never existed
but one girl still knows that you're
there a young girl who can see fairies
[Music]
it was my pleasure Lawrence thank you
very much would you like to be the
aggressor high school no sir
beautiful Tambor do you think so lucky
me I can't believe how good you are at
by liberate someone's improved must have
really been putting in the hours I knows
well I did what I could but if I've
improved it all it's thanks to Murray
you haven't missed a beat Nils I doubt
even knew would recognize you're playing
it's someone there
are you a fairy thank you for your gift
that night I hope we can meet properly
one day well then goodbye kind fairy
you
you
you